đổi thường đổi thường đơn vị viem chính thủy quan lục chiến số 2.2
đã được chiến khai từ bùng cari bay để hỗ trợ chiến 6,000 spiệp
nhìn vô sợ bộ thường lạnh biên năm hoặc kỳ tinh hành,
nhằm vật tập buồn mà tôi bị cá bộ sơ phát tử vình như thế là
đằng phim cùng bố chứ thấy lực lượng miế dời tạo USS Son, Antonio,
sử dụng thuyên chiến và bắn đạn thật và các vật thể bất hơi dưới nước
theo lần năm góc, chiến sình đã thực hiện 2 mốt của tấn công
tiêu dịch tảm hiai đối tượng đủ miế gọi là khủ bộ mà tôi
họ đừng ngày khiến khăn thẳng giữa Washington và Thara Khác Liao Thang
khi bên dưới là cá mục mi hành động mang tính đi của
cho bối kinh gão tổng thống Maduro Sâm nhật
đã có khu diện đàn với tổng thống đương nơi trâm
mũ tả để là cuộc trò chuyện tông trọng và mang tính thiện chi
giữa phát đi nhiều kánh bảo mạnh mẽ tổng thống đương nơi trọng vẫn nhìn mạnh
sáng sàng đối thoại và thử diện thích hợp
cho thấy 2 bên dưới chỉ xong xong xong xong xe et và kinh li là
của điện đàn được xanh lưỡ bức giảm giận mang tính đều tượng
chân kê hôm nay tiếp theo của quan hệ Mỹ bên dưới lài vẫn phụ thuận ngọt thảo lần
và các Washington trên thái chính dịch chống Maduro I trong thời gian tới